la guerre en Ukraine des explosions à
Kiev entendu ce matin une nouvelle
offensive russe découvre pures d'eau et
de courante étaient signalées dans
plusieurs villes du pays on retrouve
Gulliver crack notre correspondant à
Kiev quelle est la situation dans la
capitale Ukraine ce matin
alors il semblerait que c'est la
première fois en fait depuis le 26
novembre que des missiles russes ont
atteints leur cible sur les
infrastructures du système d'électricité
de Kiev dont trois quartiers différents
les autorités confirment qu'il y a eu
des frappes et par conséquence il y a
des coupures d'électricité dites
d'urgence ça veut dire au-delà des
coupures d'électricité programmée que
toute la capitale subit maintenant
depuis le 10 octobre
il y a l'alerte est encore en place
alors beaucoup de monde s'est abrité
dans le métro qui ne fonctionne pas
faute d'électricité les trains ne
circulent pas mais les stations de métro
sont ouvertes ainsi que la gare des
trains ou thé café distribués aux gens
qui soient attendent leur train soit
s'ils sont rendus juste pour s'abriter
dont les passages souterraines une
vingtaine de train en Ukraine ont des
délais de plus d'une heure ce qui
témoigne de l'échelle de cette attaque
aujourd'hui et du fait que des cibles
ont été atteints contrairement aux
autres attaques récentes ou les systèmes
de défense ont été aériennes ont eu des
résultats assez impressionnants il y a
deux jours 13 drones sur 13 sur les
régions de Kev avait été abattu et par
conséquent il y avait juste quelques
endommagements pas très importants sur
sur des immeubles d'administration
aujourd'hui c'était des roquettes et
même si bien sûr la défense antérienne a
travaillé plusieurs missiles ont été
interceptés nous même on les a entendus
tout de même il y a eu des cibles qui
ont été atteints et le maire de Kiev a
dit qu'il est fort possible que il va y
avoir des coupures aussi de la
distribution d'eau vitalité au conseil à
tous les habitants de Kiev de remplir
leur baignoire ou des sauts ce qu'ils
ont pour faire des stocks d'eau parce
que il est fort probable selon
l'Amérique ils vont devoir couper un lot
ce qui veut dire très probablement que
le chauffage sera coupé aussi dans les
immeubles ou le chauffage et centralisés
et dépend des centrales de chauffage en
dehors des immeubles Gulliver qu'en
est-il des frappes russes dans les
autres régions
oui c'est toute l'Ukraine qui a été
ciblée ce matin plusieurs capitales
régionales sont sans électricité à cause
des frappes Poltava notamment
cropernity ça c'est dans le centre du
pays plus à l'est arquive la deuxième
ville du pays apparemment totalement
sans électricité ce matin pour clope
Meetic en fait c'est toute la région
autour qui subit un blackout total et la
plus à l'ouest dont j'ai des
informations pour le moment c'est dans
la région de gitomir soit environ deux
heures de route à l'ouest de Kiev 60
missiles au total tirés par les Russes
ce matin selon la porte-parole des
forces stellaires
Ukrainiens on n'a pas encore
d'informations sur quel pourcentage de
ces requêtes ont pu être interceptés par
les missiles solaires mais visiblement
c'est un petit peu plus réussi si vous
voulez si on peut employer ce terme
aujourd'hui pour les Russes que les deux
dernières tentatives de monter des
frappes cette échelle merci beaucoup
Gulliver crack pour toutes vos
informations et vos